joining us now is the Armed Forces
Minister James heapey from just across
the road Ministry of Defense Mr hippie
good morning to you thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
what's the point of Liz truss as prime
minister now
Liz is the elected leader of our party
and the Prime Minister United Kingdom
she's hard at work in the building
behind you delivering for our nation
she's referred to uh jokingly by people
including George Osborne as Pino prime
minister in name only
that's not a name that I recognize but
she's been very uh candid about the
mistake that was made uh and she's
apologized for that and I think that
that counts for a lot there's leadership
in doing that but I think people forget
that there is more to being prime
minister than what you see on camera and
right now we are in a world where some
really big decisions have to be made the
global economy is moving in a direction
where all major economies around the
world are needing to react and those are
big decisions for the prime minister to
take with her Chancellor but so too are
there real security concerns uh right
now which requires some really big
decisions uh with her fellow world
leaders and I can see a prime minister
who is at hard at work on doing those
things and I grateful that she was quick
in making the change and crucially in
apologizing into the British people for
the mistake that was made but she is
very much our prime minister and for
what it's worth I think that she is
doing a good job
she didn't choose to
this U-turn it was forced upon her
wasn't it
absolutely okay and there is and I don't
think anybody disputes that it was
forced upon her for two reasons firstly
by her own admission she and the
previous Chancellor chose to go too far
and too fast uh with a package of
measures that would have
potentially brought growth quicker to
the UK economy but were out of kilter
with where the markets were at that
moment and then add to that that there
is a big International movement going on
in the global economy right now I think
the IMF overnight have pointed to the
fact that
um other major European economies are
likely to go into recession Bloomberg I
think have said that it's very likely
that the us is going to go into
recession so when you when you put those
two things together a mistake in that
she sought to go too far too fast within
the setting of a global economic
situation of course this was forced upon
her and it took an enormous amount of
courage and Leadership to recognize that
make the change quickly apologize to the
British people which I think you would
reflect I hope is a contrast to a year
ago when the previous Prime Ministers
woes began she has fronted up to her
mistake very quickly
um and you know there are people in the
Parliamentary party who don't want that
to be an end of it but I think for an
awful lot of us we recognize that this
is a moment when the country needs its
government to knuckle down and get back
on with the day job
with all due respect Mr hippy she's
changed her mind because the markets
were tanking if the bank of England
hadn't stepped in the pensioners would
not have had their Pension funds
protected by the bank of England she had
no other choice than to do a vault fast
did you support when you heard the mini
Budget on the 23rd of September did you
think that's a good idea or did you
think what on Earth are they playing at
no I Look to be completely honest with
UK when the mini budget was presented to
us in the cabinet meeting uh immediately
for the before the Chancellor's
statement each and every one of those
measures was consistent with the
approach to growth that the government
was seeking and we all in gov in cabinet
accept Collective responsibility for the
fact that that mini budget was given and
it is important for all of us to be very
honest about that it's not just the
Prime Minister who made that mistake
although she has owned it and apologized
for it
are you sorry yes 100 I I just you know
the the reality is that that scale of
intervention
based on borrowing
at a moment when the guilts market was
as vulnerable as it is because of these
ldi mechanisms that have become so
pervasive uh within Pension funds
is not sustainable it was a it was a
mistake and the intervention that was
required from the bank of England
thereafter was very necessary but so too
has been the government's decision to
roll back on many of those measures
though it's important to note that the
national and insurance cut the stamp
Duty cut and crucially the intervention
on energy bills still stands but beyond
that the government has rode back
because it recognizes that the markets
are important the rate at which the
government borrows is absolutely
essential to the stability of our
economy and our spending plans going
forward and the Prime Minister has
addressed that
okay so the whole cabinet all supported
this mini budget before it was put to
the House of Commons is that what you
just said yes
okay so none of you knew what you were
doing so why on Earth are you still
running the country
well okay I'm not sure that I think that
that is fair comments I think that the
uh the budget was presented to cabinet
and each and every one of the measures
within it were in and off themselves
coherent with a plan to drive growth but
if you're asking why I think I as a
defense minister deserve to continue to
sit around the cabinet table or I would
reflect that we here in the ministry of
Defense are doing a good job of keeping
our nation safe at a time of incredible
Global insecurity my boss Ben Wallace is
in Washington this morning uh having the
sort of conversations that foreign
beyond belief really the fact that we're
at a time when these sort of
conversations are necessary
um I think that in this department we've
done a good job and we've got a good
record on which to stand and actually I
could say the same for every other
colleague around governments in their
Department too
to keep our country safe we need to keep
our economy safe and we saw immediately
that the markets thought you'd all lost
your minds
well I I think we're in violence
agreements I've been very honest with
you throughout this interview as the
Prime Minister was in her interview last
night that the reaction of the markets
caused a change in plan that was a plan
that was changed quickly and the prime
minister's owned and apologized for
but the fact is that the markets have
since been reassured and that is also a
good thing and a reflection of her
leadership and the fact that she now has
a Chancellor in number 11 in whom the
city has confidence and that is that is
a good thing
how many more mistakes can she afford to
make
well I suspect given how uh skittish our
politics are at the moment not very many
but she wouldn't have wanted to have
made the mistake that she's made
to her credit she has owned it and
apologized for it but my experience of
the Prime Minister when she was foreign
secretary and Secretary State for
international trade and the the
international facing departments work
quite closely as we deliver our nation's
foreign policy is that the Prime
Minister makes good decisions based on
the evidence she listens to her
officials and throughout her time as
Secretary of State for international
trade and foreign secretary I think a
record shows that there is no hiding
from the fact that a mistake was made
around the mini budget but it's one that
she has owned and apologized for and now
crucially the country needs its
government to get on with the task at
hand because there is an awful lot in
the entry
how many more mistakes can she make for
you
well I I just so many hey I just said I
I don't think that there's the
opportunity to make any more mistakes
because the nation needs a government
that is governing well and is making
good decisions the nation also needs a
government that is honest where mistakes
are made
okay and if she does make any more
mistakes from what you're saying she's
toast
um it does look as though potentially
your department may have to suffer Cuts
uh we're hearing that potentially 15
percent across the board is what the uh
foreign the previous foreign secretary
now uh Chancellor de facto prime
minister some people are calling him if
there are cuts to your department that
mean that we don't see the two and a
half percent uh of GDP spent on defense
three percent by 2028 what does that
mean for you
well there's there's a number of things
that you said there that weren't quite
right if you'll allow so the commitment
that the Prime Minister made is three
percent by 2030 uh and to be clear
um like the Secretary of State
um that is something that I believe must
be delivered given the need to keep our
nation safe in increasingly uncertain
times you you cannot have Prosperity at
home or internationally without security
and that is a really good reason to be
investing in defense now if in the very
immediate term there is a requirement to
look at what we can do to help the
treasury out that's a discussion for the
chancellor to have with the secretary of
state but I am confident that the Prime
Minister and the chancellor and the
foreign secretary and frankly everyone
else around government understands the
importance of investing in our nation's
armed forces and our defenses at a time
when the UK interest at home and abroad
is under such threat okay so if I said
to you if there were Cuts in the
ministry defense budget in the short
term would that impact on our support
for Ukraine I know what you would say
you would say no so I would then have to
put it to you if I may Mr hupy that
would mean Brits uh elsewhere around the
world would find themselves in a
difficult position
well okay I think that that is true
there is there are some very hard
choices to make and we have to be very
clear on why we are doing what we're
doing in Ukraine why it's so important
to be supporting the Ukrainian Armed
Forces why it's so important to be
investing in our own Defense Forces at
the moment and that's because the cost
of not doing those things is that we
will be living in a Europe in a world
whereby it has been shown that if you
are willing to be belligerent and use
Force to threaten the sovereignty of
another country you can succeed but the
International Community loses patience
that it blinks and it dips in and you
get your way and what that does is set
us on a trajectory for the rest of this
Century whereby we will be having to
spend a lot more on our defense and
security and where our economy will be
profoundly impacted by that insecurity
so this is this is about investing now
in the ukrainians so that they can do do
the right thing in order to draw a line
underneath Putin's aggression to show
that a rules-based International System
still applies in this century
and I think that all of your viewers
would agree but that is the right thing
to be doing because the alternative is a
world that is more unstable more
insecure and a whole lot less prosperous
Mr hippie Authority if you would please
sir about our Top Guns heading off to
China to train potentially future
enemies how to fly planes
yeah and it's been a concern within the
mod for a number of years uh
counter-intelligence people have been
looking at it closely uh we are we have
approached the people that are involved
uh and been clear with them that it is
our expectation that they would not
continue to be part of that organization
and we are going to put into law that
once people have been given that warning
it would become an offense to then go uh
forward and continue with that training
um China is a competitor that
um is threatening the UK interest uh in
many places around the world it's also
an important trading partner but there
is no secret in their attempt to gain
access to our secrets and the
recruitment of our Pilots uh in order to
understand the capabilities of our air
force is clearly a concern to us and the
intelligence uh part of the mad
okay so don't be a tray to come home
before you can't and we put you in jail
well I yeah don't go and train foreign
Air Forces without checking with the mod
whether they're a foreign Air Force that
we want to see you train would be a
pretty good rule
okay good to see you Mr hoopy thank you
very much indeed for joining us